hello everyone I'm very glad you enjoyed
that game I posted yesterday young
Vincent really crushed to the field in
the Greinke chest open tournament but
here we have a game from the Greinke
chest classic round 3
it's German grandmaster Georg Meier
against World Chess Championship
challenger Fabiano Caruana and ever
since Fabiano won the candidates it's a
bit different to play against him than
before he actually won the candidates
now if you by any chance win a game
against him you'll always be able to say
ah you know that one time at in at the
Greinke chess festival I defeated the
world champion if corwin I ever beat
skulls and in their World Chess
Championship match so I mean definitely
the stakes are now higher that he is the
Challenger and it's it's an excellent
game I decided to show it because it
features one line against against the
against the efore in the rural opus that
is extremely interesting but you'll see
what I mean by this and I don't have any
photos of this encounter as it is a rest
day today at the cranky chess classic
but you know the video production team
thinks that if it's a rest day for the
players that it's a rest day for them
which you know I don't think it is but
ok but I do have one photo of them here
we have Georg Meier and Fabiano Caruana
and Mathias blue bomb there in the
background probably probably you know
taking a stroll relaxing from his own
game and checking out other games and
it's it's a photo that was sent to me by
Enzo Kaiser his subscriber he contacted
me over Instagram and he will be there
every day so if I will not be having any
official photos I will always have at
least one photo or two to use from Enzo
so thank you what Enzo
I'm very glad you sent the photos to me
and I also prepared the standings after
round 3 but I'll show you this after the
game so let's see the game
Georg Meier has the white pieces and he
opens with E 4 we have e5 Knight f3
knight c6 and Bishop to b5 so the real
opus like we said a six and now Bishop
captures on c6 Bishop captures on c6 is
one of the reasons I never play
Lopez as black and this game actually
might mid me might make me change my
opinion he captures on c6 by Caruana
castles and now Queen to f6 the exchange
variation of the real opus is something
that in any book you read will tell you
that white doesn't really have anything
here but if if white plays a solid moves
then he he will actually have some long
long long term advantage like Bobby
Fischer was a big fan of this variation
and he crushed many opponents in this in
this variation but I really hate it hate
playing it would black so probably the
exchange variation of the real opus is
the reason why I never play it with
black but like I said after d4e capture
some d4 and the Bishop to g5 karana
played Queen to b6 and now comes the
night captures on d4 winning back the
pawn Bishop to e7 and here you don't
really want to capture the bishop this
would only this would only help healthy
black develop now you can simply castle
the world the light square Bishop either
way black will be perfectly fine here
so mark goes back to e3 sorry we have 90
to h6 now and Queen to d2 and here we
have g5 and this is the move I really
like and this is why I really enjoyed
this game because in the candidates
tournament you had the game where
Kramnik played the g5 move in the Berlin
and now you have Fabiano Kawana
employing g5 in the exchange variation
of the rule opus so this is this is very
interesting stuff and really making the
variation interesting so what do you do
here obviously if you capture it you get
Bishop captures queen captors and rook
the g8 you're not gonna have a lot of
fun here as white you move the Queen
Queen characters Queen captures and now
after Queen capture some b2 you do have
to protect the rook night to d2 and now
Queen the c3 not allowing the Queen to
capture here as the the knight and e2 is
attacked
but even if you even if you try this
then you're gonna lose the game
immediately because rook to h8 actually
traps your Queen so the Queen has
nowhere to go but either either way a
very interesting idea g5 so Knight to f3
opening up a discovered attack on
Fabiano's Queen on d6
and now rook the g8 and here Meier can
definitely play Queen captures Bishop
captures blue push h4 next but he
decides to keep the Queen's on the board
he plays h4 immediately we have Queen 2
g 6h captures on g5 and now Knight to g4
so Fabiano's plan is play h6 exchange
the pawn here make make an open H file
for the rook place the rooks on the H
file and attack the White King and g1
so Knight to c3 we have h6 mmm
Bishop to f4 and now Bishop to e6 Bishop
captures on c7 Meier thinks he does have
time to grab on here I roped the c8
pushing the bishop back Bishop to b6 and
now H captures on g5 finally opening up
the H file 9 3 2 bringing the night over
to g3 to help out with the defense c5
now not allowing this bishop to protect
the king side anymore we have night 2 G
3 and now rook h8 rook F to D 1 if this
bishop ever moves then maybe Queen to d7
will become an idea
Queen to h6 now the Knights are placed
on f3 in g3 but if they ever moved then
Queen to h2 and h1 could become a thing
before now here the idea is marwan's
Fabiano to capture so the bishop can can
become active again here
Bishop to f6 would have been the best
idea for Fabi after Bishop to f6 this
would this would prevent Mars idea
completely as it comes into game with a
temple on the rook but ok see capture
some before and now butter up to d4 now
this Bishop and this becomes a very
powerful piece on d4
also comes with a temp on the rook on h8
here f6 by Fabi blocking the attack on
the rook and we have c3 now B captors on
c3 be captures on c3 and here King to f7
was played Fabiano doesn't doesn't allow
Queen to d7 to come with check but here
he actually missed
a crushing move that completely
obliterates white here he had night to
h2 night to h2 with the idea of night of
course capturing an f3 and then the
Queen can come all the way to h2 and
here you do have to play Knight to e1 to
prevent any ideas after the Queen checks
the king and the King comes to f1 then
rush of the c4 check will be met with
Knight 2 D 3 so nice to e 1 I move you
absolutely have to play but then comes
the Bishop to g4 you attack the rook
after f3 and now Queen to h4 you capture
the bishop Queen captures Queen captures
night here and after Queen to d7 check
King to f7 and as you can see a black is
black is completely crushing disposition
the bishop on c3 is attacked twice by
drokken by the Queen and the position is
very much in blacks favour knife
captures and g4 is coming with threats
of Queen f2 Queen h2 a pretty terrible
position for white but ok after Queen to
c3 Fabi first decided to go King to f7
and then rook a to c1 was played and
here father plays rook to C for now
could he have gone nice to h2 again
there was this a very interesting
variation and now with the threat of
capturing an f2 and f3 once again and
there was an interesting variation what
if white tries a Knights the d4 to
prevent this now the knight on h2 looks
pretty silly but now you actually get
knife to f1 and the white is lost
what's the idea of course there's the
threat of capturing and then coming to
h1 and after white accepts this King
captures an f1 now we'll get Bishop to
c4 check King to e1 and now Queen
captures on h1 sacrificing the Queen
Knight captures rook captures and this
is checkmate the bishop is keeping the
King away from escaping but the problem
is after Knight 2 h2 now here Meyer
would have Knight captors and g5 and
black has nothing here you have captures
Bishop captures and a trade rook
captures and now rock - the rock to c7
Knight to g4 but simply Queen to d6 and
now you're threatening uncapped
the bishop on e7 and after queen comes
to check rook has to help out with the
defense and there is no way for black to
continue his attack white is perfectly
fine here
so here Fabi goes rook to c4 and Meier
blocks the the attack on the e4 pawn
with Bishop to d4
we have b5 and here Queen to a5 here I
must move for Meier was rook captures on
c4 after Bishop captures rook to c1 the
game continues there is no there is no
real way for black to do anything here
on the Queen side but for some reason
Meier decided to play Queen to a5 it's
like he he's like saying if Abby doesn't
have anything here on the Queen side I
have enough time to grab a pawn here
Fabi plays finally Knight 2 h2 and here
Knight to e1 I was again a must move for
Meier but he says Fabi you've got
nothing here I'm gonna capture the pawn
so Queen captures on a6 Fabi says ok
Knight captures on f3
Jean captures on f3 and now Fabi goes
g4g 4 is is a good move it's probably a
move that will in the long run win for
black but here Fabi Fabi misses again a
crushing idea Queen to h2 check it seems
like an obvious move of course everyone
wants to play Queen to h2 check but it's
it's very hard to find a follow up
because the idea is after King to f1 now
the winning move is actually rook H to
c8 and this is something I don't think
anyone would see because it's totally
not logical I mean why why would you
move your look away from the H file
you've planned your entire game haha to
open up the H file to attack the White
King and now you want to bring your rook
all the way to see it and now the idea
here is that black is actually
threatening rook captures and c1 which
wins the game
and another thing a black is threatening
rook captures on d4 because I have to
recapture Sun before either white will
capture here and then black will capture
the rook on c1 or white will capture the
rook on c8 and then you will
after capturing honey the undie for
capture the rock on d1 and win the game
so here you don't really have any move
for white
if you cry Bishop to b2 just simply
guard the rook and c1 and allow any of
these captures then rub the c2 winds and
there is no defense against Queen
captures on f2 you could try rock
captures rook captures again there's the
threat of capturing and after this maybe
last last attempt by white - maybe
defend the f2 pawn and prevent Bishop to
c5 as the bishop is pinned here now
better to h3 wins the game King moves
now Queen g1 check 92 Knight f1 and
Queen captures on f1 this is checkmate
so this is a move Fabi missed this going
to h2 check but I don't think anyone
would find a rock h2 c8 simply because I
you don't expect there to be such a move
but okay he played the g4 we have F for
now not allowing to open up Queen
captures on f4 and now rook captures on
c4 b captures on c4 and Bishop to e3
attacking the Queen Queen to f3 and it's
extremely hard to find a move here for
white you can't move your knight if you
move the night you get a rock to H 1
this would be checkmate fabi's plan is
very clear Fabi wants to play rook to h3
and capture the night here and you don't
have any way of preventing this March
ride rook to d6 with the idea of either
black will capture and then maybe the
Queen will get some perpetual ideas or
he will simply capture the bishop here
but of course Fabi ignores them rook to
h3 now Meier doesn't really have a move
here you can't move the knight so rook
captures and now comes the rook captures
and g3 this is with check F captures
Queen captures on e3 would check King to
h2 and here Queen to f2 check King to h1
and here probably played Queen to f1
check and it was in this position that
Jeremiah resigned to the game because
I'm sure all of you can see what what
follows next it's a force checkmate in
to feel free to find it
feel free to even pause the video if you
don't see it immediately but time for
all of you do so I'm not going
wait for you to pause the video the
ideas after King to h2 queen h3 is
coming King do you want and then Bishop
finally place moves to c5 and this is
now checkmate
the queen is slicing all the way to f1
so yeah after Queen to f1 check my
resigned the game and a very nice win
for Fabiana Caruana and I think that I
might actually start playing a five and
the rule and the rule opus maybe with
the black pieces because now you have so
many options here you could play you can
go for the Marshall attack you could go
for the g5 variation of the Berlin like
Kramnik showed us you now have the g5
variation in in the exchange variation
of the real opus which I'm sure is not a
novelty I just I just don't think I've
ever seen it so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Mark Wetzler ken Stefan Jesse
bellhart mark Gayle bond field Rivas and
Rachel Simmons for a contribution to my
channel I think a lot I really
appreciate it and I want one other
special announcement I would like to
congratulate a happy birthday to Mattia
who is a 22 year old professional
handball player from Croatia and not
only that he's soon to finish college so
I'm very I'm very happy his girlfriend
Anna contacted me and requested me to
congratulate him a happy birthday
because in a weird way it really does
make me happy that people are people are
starting to consider a chess channel
like a cool place to wish someone a
happy birthday yeah maybe I maybe it's
not to congratulate someone maybe it's
to wish someone happy birthday so either
way I'm very happy you contacted me and
once again
Mattia happy birthday to you and I hope
you celebrate it like a boss so that's
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
another interesting video and of course
I forgot I I did not show you to find
the standings after round three so here
they are
these are the standings after round
three of the Greinke chess classic in
first place for now maxime beaugeois
grove with two and a half out of three
points and nikita be tube of also two
and a half points out of three then we
have with two
Levon Aronian magnus carlsen and Caruana
Fabiano are on the the defender of the
title he is the winner of the cranky
chess classic of 2017 so we'll see if he
can do it again this year then with one
point Viswanathan Anand and Matias blue
bump also RK denied itch and with half a
point each only one draw a holy fan and
Georg Meyer after losing this game to
Fabiano Caruana so yeah those were the
standings I do hope you enjoyed all of
this thank you all and I will see you
soon